INTERVIEWER: This is a
pretty weird combination
of festive and ominous.
The guy here is
dressed to the nines.
He doesn't look concerned,
and neither do the horses,
for that matter.
But there's that face mask.
Is the guy sick?
Is the horse sick?
Is it just allergy season?
Thankfully, we have
some answers, courtesy
of the man behind the camera.
RODRIGO GONZALEZ: Hi.
My name's Rodrigo Gonzalez.
I am a photojournalist
in Mexico City.
This photo was taken
in the Alameda Central
in downtown Mexico City.
It's a huge part park, and a
very popular touristic spot.
INTERVIEWER: Which is the
reason the masked man was there.
He's an officer in a force
known as The Tourist Police.
RODRIGO GONZALEZ: This group
was created to help and guard
tourists visiting
the Alameda, so they
are dressed with a mix of police
uniform and typical charro
garments.
A charro is a traditional
Mexican horseman,
and also is one of the
most recognizable symbols
of Mexican culture.
Like the Mounty for
Canada, or the cowbody
for the United States.
INTERVIEWER: But
that still doesn't
explain why this officer
is wearing a face mask.
RODRIGO GONZALEZ: The photo
was taken on April 26th, 2009.
It was taken when an epidemic
swine flu, or influenza, was
declared in Mexico City as
part of a worldwide pandemic
of the virus.
INTERVIEWER: The 2009
influenza pandemic
was not something to ignore.
Eventually it killed over
14,000 people worldwide.
That's why the officer
was wearing a mask.
And he wasn't alone.
Many Mexican citizens
protected themselves this way.
They were worn in
churches and schools,
by the media and
the military, but it
was just one small precaution
Mexicans took during that time.
RODRIGO GONZALEZ: What
I took his picture,
the health emergency
was just starting.
At that time, we had no idea
that some days later, Mexico
City would almost get to stop.
public transportation
would stop,
supermarkets were
emptied, and everyone
would be in their homes,
protecting themselves
from the virus.
It was crazy.
INTERVIEWER: And what
Rodrigo saw and experienced
taking pictures that day was
like nothing he'd ever seen.
RODRIGO GONZALEZ:
Seeing the streets
of the city almost empty at
rush hour, it was unbelievable.
It was like one of
those Sunday movies.
INTERVIEWER: Hey, everyone.
Thanks for watching
"This Happened Here."
If you liked this episode,
be sure to check out
this one on why
thousands of people
disappeared in Argentina
during the Dirty War.
SUBJECT 2: Many of the mothers
came together in their grief.
They began to
demand toe be heard,
wanting to know where
their children were.
When they were not given any
information, 14 mothers began--
INTERVIEWER: And don't
forget to subscribe.